may I introduce to my new wife Colette
the wild days of Danny on the contrary
the wild days have just begun he married
literary entrepreneur you've married a
country girl fat penny to her name
doom Davi Willy is a brand I take all
the risk and the silver money output you
you could write my school stories yes
that could be Willy's next novel you're
writing for him too
yes he's made you one of his ghosts
already my name is Claudia I live in
Montana I should probably not die there
is beautiful we've never had one fly off
the shelves like this before
and delivers by young women as ever I
have a little plan to turn Claudine into
the most popular girl in the entire
world I believe with a base called e on
your schooldays yes I think I had a
little something to contribute finally
we have a success and then you imply
that I'm not the true author of it
people love to talk I understand the
mentality here you don't I understand it
well enough to write a book this toast
of Paris you've done something important
all those young girls we've given them
of us you should own up to it he was
after you your jealousy is misplaced how
so it was the wife I found interesting
we're holding dynamite here that could
blow our bloody heads off since what if
you considered scandal to be a bad thing
oh how interesting your love line splits
into three must get used to marriage
better to make marriage it is to you
people are begging for more
I don't want to write another protein
are you out of your mind
right no one can take away who you are
destroy this incinerated
[Music]
trap me when I knew nothing
we wondered meteor and desires
and you thought that I could never break
free
are you're wrong
and holds the patent rights history
[Music]